[Music]
[Applause]
and we're off hi guys welcome to we
might be drunk the number one podcast
featuring me today oh yeah my host today
are Mark Norman and Sam Morrell thanks
for having us on yeah you're welcome
good to see you again all right you on
YouTube boy you might have beat
stavros's record it's already at 4.3
yeah do you feel like you got a bump due
to Kanye no question no question we
worked it out for a while he's like I'm
ready to go off my dude cow give me
three weeks yeah I'm releasing this
thing in no time just give me a few
weeks he's like all right I gotta meet
Trump then I'll meet with you yeah he
goes it's the Arabs of you I'm like make
it the Jews
yeah Kyrie two you got a couple you got
a couple nice bonds you know what's
scared about the Kyrie stuff is I I'll
go click on it and it's just people
going facts yep sing it sister and
you're like oh that's when you get
scared when some crazy guy's talking
it's funny about Kanye too is like he
posted he was like hey I saw this here's
a link to this thing I saw everyone's
like kill [ __ ] you it's just on Amazon
though yeah it's not like he uncovered
it from the hidden like Nazi Chambers
it's readily available everyone's like
no that's fine but him watching it no no
no no no oh yeah anti-Semitism got bad
because I got written up as an article
in this article recently uh as openly
Jewish openly true that's how you know
shit's getting kind of dicey yeah well I
think the eyebrows said that this could
be this could be uh that's true that's
true you could blend yeah
I got some Turkish in here you can
collaborate we got some vodkas sir I
want to try a vodka dude sour cream damn
but we just ate at a deli we should
no it'll beef barley and a cabbage with
the meat in it stuffed cabbage oh I love
a stuff Mark really is like this close
to being a Jew I wish he really is
you're like on the
way except for the hatred I'll take
everything else I would say you're the
Rachel Doles all of Jews oh don't drive
so hard yeah
yes
[Laughter]
well thanks Peters you really did it up
here this is almost offensive
if I was like I didn't sign up for any
of this I'm just gonna talk about my new
book well do you have a a bit of a
hatred because you went so far in and
then you got the hell out you were
Orthodox for a half minutes yeah and now
you're you went the other way it's like
a preacher's daughter thing where you
got hoary so what are you saying so I'm
saying do you have like a weird uh
resentment towards the heebs nah I did
for a little bit no I can't not even
enough distance no I have enough
distance so I love him but I like Jay
Leno
jaywalking is lame and then you're like
ah this guy's got cars he's all right I
like Jay man and he uh I'm glad he's
okay you heard he just went up the other
night at the comedy magic
is open or what yeah but he just was lit
on fire and minora got him wait oh no I
did not hear that you didn't know he was
all about he's all jacked up he's okay
he's open it was I didn't know I was a
roast comic like he arrested me
no it was an engine a gasoline fire and
it got on his face and his face caught
fire yeah yeah the worst episode of
comedian cars yeah
very hot coffee
the show really is like Comedians and
Cars but for people with germaphobia
there he is and still in the denim they
got him denim scrubs just to be nice we
did it we threw into an actor strike I
took out my sad card the commercials
Union was going on strike and so we're
out there picketing [ __ ] I didn't care
about I just needed that card yeah and
uh he rolled by well by three times our
Hawkins like you keep fighting damn look
at that he looks like a like a sack a
little bit he's got the burns looks like
he was taken by a flip phone
happy I text him I know him a little bit
whoa you're okay text and he wrote back
immediately oh wow who's this no he
wrote back thanks so he says thanks Sam
wow that's fire yeah all right who are
these [ __ ] nurses taking a picture
with a man who's just been scarred he's
like let's take a [ __ ] public picture
now he's a tough guy he's like already
back at it rolling with it he'll never
stop working he hates the victim thing
there's a story that he went in one day
on The Tonight Show with a broken leg
what
yeah probably
what do we have going on here whoa watch
out Leno
oh my God I priced drinks for low prices
you said thematic right so yeah you got
a shot of that there Pete
how weird would it be if he lit himself
on fire right I know that'd be so
appropriate
get a lot
with the sound great touch Peter how
many Google sessions did you have to do
to figure this out
what
damn now I'm even more attracted to her
what are we doing is she Jewish ah
Danielle come on wow no wonder she likes
soda
how many comments could pass
oh good amount a good amount
what is the what do you call this is
that holla this yeah no it's um marble
rye no Bobcat no papa gold weight and
then uh what do they what's the try for
there that's a hamantasian you want a
story of that please okay didn't
Glassman tell this story what is it yeah
what is it
no there's a king and anyway he he
didn't like his Queen he was like Hey
bringing this queen a dance naked for my
[ __ ] friends here and uh and there
she was like No And he was like you're
banished
um the story is she probably had herpes
oh herpes scars you want to show him off
to her to the [ __ ] card game nice
anyway so he wanted to hunt for a new uh
a new Queen and this guy Mordechai Morty
as it were told his niece he had one hot
niece and he was like um Esther and he
goes Esther
I want you to enter the competition for
best Queen
don't [ __ ] say you're a Jew he's
gonna work against you anyway smart move
by a [ __ ] smart manager she hides it
she wins Queen he's like you're the hot
one let's [ __ ] so they [ __ ] for a while
you know
um
and then the king's right-hand man Haman
hmm
he wore this three cornered hat that'll
come back yep yep and uh he goes hey you
know the juice and alcohol's like yeah
he goes can we should like kill them
right and he's like uh yeah whatever
that's cool and so then he's like
everyone's like all right then by eating
the king he killed [ __ ] juice and
Juice you can't fight back and they're
like [ __ ] the law is the law and so and
then and then right then Esther's like
hey I got some news for you he's like
what is it my love
she's like I'm a [ __ ] Jew oh [ __ ] and
he's like what oh you're gonna hate this
law she goes no no I know about it can
you change that a lot he goes you can't
change an easy to the king and he goes
okay well then how about Jews can fight
back
and he goes all right good compromise
hey so the big win was we were allowed
to defend ourselves and at that point
the people were like this isn't as fun
so they went and got hum on they [ __ ]
strung them up whoa three-cornered hat
he always wore so now this is a tribute
yeah it's a tribute to the [ __ ] who
we hung
oh whoa yeah and then something in there
is we got I think dead drunk or
something and so now we're supposed to
get drunk on Purim oh wait that's Purim
uh oh that's a Halloween oh yeah no
completely wrong story
you should do a special about this can
you hand me a hemoglobin wait there's
one for Hanukkah huh
it's important thing you're still good
all right it's like a cool Rabbi yeah
there we go let me grab one oh you ever
not interrupted me I feel like a
congressman who's got that old joke uh I
went into the Jewish deli and I said how
much does the challah cost oh that's
pretty good Franken I think it's big J
actually in the roast he made me read it
that's a funny joke yeah Holocaust said
we all missed that one it was right
there
so uh yeah man Hanukkah what day of
Hanukkah are we doing this on by the way
is this the last day Eight Crazy Nights
yeah when is it exactly do you still
celebrate it or no no but I'll light up
a menorah if I'm going to a holiday
party it's fun to bring a menorah and
you're allowed you know regular [ __ ]
Christmas party look guys I got you and
then you [ __ ] everyone left lighting up
it's so fun and odd how do you feel
about Christmas song in a bar like this
time of year not loving them yeah
they're not sure okay
yeah yeah Santa Claus is coming to town
uh the waitresses is a good song they
have a good song The Waitresses yeah
um
it's like I'm skipping Christmas tonight
man those are great yeah there's a good
song
which is a Christmas song that's it you
got it I was literally I was flying all
day and I was literally just thinking
about when I could have a drink yeah I
don't want to I don't want to blow the
energy you know thank you I wanted some
energy for this [ __ ] cheers by the way
she didn't have congrats on ours if
you're Jew yeah on uh
I don't know where it's gonna be by the
time this comes out but it's assume 5
million oh yeah that'd be very nice yeah
welcome to the YouTube Club thanks buddy
yeah yeah we're all in there you guys
[ __ ] uh broke down the barriers
I remember we'd have these long sidewalk
conversations Ari and I were we'd be I'd
be like YouTube and always like yeah
yeah I think it's a move like it's the
future you you were thinking about it
like a while back yeah like maybe I put
it on Rogan's YouTube maybe you were
like you didn't know but now it's like
you built up yours and now it makes the
most sense oh yeah
yeah I'm so stoked on it so many people
see her very good very good yeah and
it's niche you're the only guy who could
pull this Niche off if somebody else did
a show about just Allah or something it
wouldn't get four million to be on the
FBI's Most Wanted yeah yeah yeah yeah I
try to make it funny
above all good laughs yeah
and it did yeah and it looked great with
the candles it looks so [ __ ] good
right and I think it's at your your
place we're live right yeah whoa It's a
testimony to [ __ ] how to just do some
set dressing like things don't look the
same yeah yeah you can't really tell
Crystal Stefano shot a special note Gary
Goldman is that right so yeah they all
look so different I went and scouted it
and I was like okay have you ever done
special hair they're like those two Sam
Morelos December I was like oh I was at
that you were there and I didn't
remember I got a picture of you give me
the finger like two inches in my face in
the green room it's a gym that is a gym
I don't know she's too autistic yeah
dude look how pretty I mean what is that
4 000 candles six Thousand Candles wow
almost six million almost to getting
there all right
um yeah it's been really good have any
prominent Jews reached out to you oh
now you would think somebody would I'm
waiting for Ben Shapiro to be like
what's up let's go yeah no one no one
there's got to be someone Woody Allen
prominences no you would think it would
come across the rate it's only been out
for three weeks yeah yeah Harvey's
calling all right because I'm taking
that call if Epstein were alive collect
call from preventative
all right oh my God I just watched the
Jolene Maxwell Netflix stock have you
seen this is a dock on her already yeah
it's uh well it's like no Epstein doc
there is it's the same one Filthy Rich
oh okay I've seen that Hanukkah gel baby
Hanukkah guilt the the candy that's
shaped like money the people who can't
stop thinking about it not doing wonders
for our stereo not really at all wait
it's called guilt all right no that's
what they call it if you don't get it
uh oh so it's the same duck yeah all
right that's a new one though she got
her own that's never got it wrong yeah
Julie Maxwell Filthy Rich oh they
couldn't even put her on the cover no
she she got her okay
all right we get any side boob she was
sure she was a piece she was a dime
piece oh yeah well she's a rich rich kid
imagine going from Dime Piece side piece
to just um groomer yeah yeah
how much do you love money
she couldn't she couldn't stand being
poor assistant I'll just forget this
father figure some some girls Epstein
she's like I mean it goes to show how
much the dad and you know parents should
all play a role but like her dad was
like Epstein really pedophilia was he
really he was always [ __ ] around the
mom and a shitty guy and yeah and then
she's like I'll just attach myself to
another guy like my dad but he's like
well this Daddy has got some even
weirder quirks yeah yeah I describe
pedophilia as a court probably a misfire
look he was in on her she was uh she was
yeah she was Scouting For scouting yeah
she was the front office right yeah she
was making the move like in the early
days
[Laughter]
oh yeah she was hot in her day though
don't don't love her eyebrows look at
her with Trump and whoever the [ __ ] that
is she's hot young Julian giving those
foot massages who's that chick with
Trump was that Melania she's one of the
hottest chicks in history he was
something back then she still looks good
I've seen her naked have you yeah pull
them up Melania it's my wallpaper uh but
yeah she was uh like a cover girl for a
hot minute and an escort I believe I
wish she was the first lady oh wasn't
that wild yeah wait that's Jose that's
Melania oh yeah it looks like Debbie
Harry yeah Debbie Harris no hair on her
mm-hmm look at that I mean come on
that's the first lady folks what a
country what a [ __ ] tree man
this is pretty good this is pretty good
men with ketam grape juice all right so
there's this there's this popular Golf
Course drink called the transfusion it's
just grape juice ginger ale and vodka
okay so we made it Hanukkah and you know
in light of Enlightenment in light of
doesn't sound right at all well we're
lighting the models in honor of minor in
honor of fair enough uh so it's uh catam
grape juice uh ginger ale and our Bodega
cat uh Rye with a little bit of lemon
and then you know a little uh lemon with
uh brown sugar roasted what is ketam is
that a Jew thing
it is it's grape juice juice thing it's
it's just a grape juice that's used
grape juice is it funny in lieu of like
red wine and stuff okay well Norma's got
that joke about uh how like what lucky
we're not attracted to kids like when I
was oh yeah uh when I was a kid I like
grape juice now I like red wine oh I was
a kid I was attracted to the young girls
now I like older women
but I still like grape juice yeah
something like that but it's like it's
like man I think of that every time I
see grape juice
that's so great you see a bad guy stop
thinking about it every time I see a
neck tattoo I think a Todd Barry's bit
you forgot to not do that
so easy or so simple but so funny and in
his voice just like the sarcastic dick
yeah a Tails got a million of those
where you're like oh that's in a tail
bit oh man I was watching the tell on
Ian Finance late I was it was Wednesday
night of Thanksgiving and I was just
wasted Liz and I were just pounding
martinis I Love Drunk Sam and I was just
in the doorway watching a tell on Ian
and I was just it was like you ever just
like watch Comedy we don't do it enough
anymore yeah you just hope Dave doesn't
see you because then he's gonna bring
your ass in he saw me and he was like he
goes is that one okay
yeah I'm dying I guess it is literally
the quickest guy on the planet I saw him
talking to a lady the other night he
goes you ma'am you like a vibrator she
goes I just use my fingers goes mmm
acoustic
he said to Ian he goes are you dating
anyone he goes I just had a breakup he
goes I didn't know you could break up
with a cat
so good so good they have a great
Rapport they're so good yeah they really
do what a combo and they share
cigarettes which is cute they share
cigarettes no they have I mean they like
packs they don't like pass one back and
forth no that would be weird that would
be weird I did let me get a hit off that
what Jewish food it gets a bad rap I'm
loving this [ __ ] Jewish food's great
yeah like you know I get a bad fat fish
and guess what gefilte fish is kind of
good come on if you put horseradish on
you put the horseradish the red kind or
the white yellow it's just Jello right
it's gel loaf
is it a meatloaf I love that this is so
ingrained in who Ari and I are that we
can't turn on gefilte fish
it starts with a filter fish and then it
goes to Google you can't have it we're
the NRA oh it looks like hell oh I like
it I know no we're gonna get killed in
the comments they got me that helium
once and they're just like we got your
thing I give Health fish and I was like
I'll play this place again
oh wow he took it at your
[Laughter]
that's the natural kind you want the
unnatural kind that's the original form
peanut butter you don't want the uh you
don't want that oil I want to give it
oils too much the peanut butter oil is
like get the [ __ ] out of here you're
gonna stir it like you're a wicked witch
Amish give me the gif that's what you
want the unnatural kind that you're
slicing up what that's what it looks
like it's a better card I thought it was
green for some reason what do you think
I was picturing Jello you ever eat like
and also a lot of dewy food is also like
kind of that Ukrainian Russian type food
it's great
Polaris sometime over this winter I
don't even know what that is it's an
Eastern European Jewish stew pull it up
c-h-o-l-e-n-t let's call it that
chilling there we go oh yeah baby I'm
bringing it it's hearty looks like a
chili
pierogi that's what I'm thinking of slow
cooking pierogies are great so good 15
hours wow that does look good it's like
a slow cooker if you're not bombing
anybody with it it's like a pot roast
damn that looks so good
oh that's right up my alley especially
in the winter man yeah boy that'll make
it a really [ __ ] Christmas music yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah I kind of like a good
like getting loaded in a bar with
Christmas music
a little bit you feel like you're
passing through yeah and then you go out
in that cold wind hits you yeah it's
kind of it's kind of fun to drink like
also you know I love about the winter
drinking is the warm warm drinks
yeah we gotta get this either mulled
wine or hot cider hot cider is big
he's a killer hot toddy's underrated
love it that's what you should call Todd
Berry from now on I've been getting on
her for years make a [ __ ] mulled wine
love them all do it and you smell it
smell it got the Apple stick or whatever
that is in there cinnamon stick for a
hot toddy I would say because it's
easier to bash and easier to serve out
so a lot of people what is potties like
you're gonna have to do it like
individually but you can just warm up
something in the microwave or something
yeah I mean you know you have a kettle
or whatever but mold wine is just nicer
it's hot sangria effectively
like I don't know if I've ever had
mulled wine is delicious it's good it's
good really really good it will make me
stop if I see a sign outside a sandwich
board it's a mold wine I'm going in 100
yeah and it warms you up we gotta do an
end with it well we can absolutely do
that all right running back over the
summer and then what is in a hot tub
that's whiskey whiskey tea uh cinnamon
um
cinnamon and other spices like
alcoholics drink when they're [ __ ] it's
like pasta people like this will help
you get better
just feel better speaking of Boston
people yeah like I was in Fort Wayne
over the weekend and we're just watching
movies in between the shows so Dina had
never seen the town and I was like oh
the town is so good
such a [ __ ] good one it's so good
that's so [ __ ] underrated that movie
it's great like what do they take over
Fenway yeah of course yeah like every
scene Affleck's rocking like a a broom
shirt yeah I can wear my own stuff
no costume designer there was a hot
minute when like 10 year nine year span
where Boston was everything it was like
it started with Goodwill Hunting and
then there's like townies departed
departed River Gone Baby Gone it was a
lot of product writer Dennis Lee Hayne
they could just adapt like every one of
his books into a movie they just like
fit perfectly right what's the one he
did with that uh chick from ET
and then and then they just won every
championship in sports for like 15 years
yeah that was like that no one rooted
for them oh dude they had one Red Sox
now Brady's gone
oh the cop can we play this
all right
[Laughter]
they let him go
get out of here man can we kill this guy
that's very realistic I could see a cop
just being like ah [ __ ] it yeah
literally looking the other way on the
nose I was seeing with the florist where
he's cutting the roads oh yeah scary guy
that's the one that like really got me
Pete possible ways how's that guy live
with himself how about you know he's
like [ __ ] I'm dead if I do anything if I
just but also they're gone now calling
in uh that's true no he made a deal with
him he's honorable what about uh [ __ ]
the the classic it's like such a cliche
but it's such a badass line where
Affleck just walks in he's like I need
you to beat up some guys with me you
can't ask me about it now you can't ask
me about it later and uh we're gonna
hurt some people and and Runner just
goes whose car are we taking no that's a
badass moment I butchered the line but
that's a friend
oh yeah oh yeah it's badass as [ __ ] this
is oh the fighter was another one yeah
that's
yeah you nailed it
this is his best roll Runner Runner this
is before Marvel right yeah yeah dude I
did a commercial with him yeah my first
commercial he was uh he was he we did
two Kia commercials he was in the other
one we had to go to the Grand Canyon
what did he go to Monument Valley pull
it up
yeah he did the other one
is that it
there he is I was friends with that girl
I feel like Ari's about to get cut out
is that this wasn't the one I was doing
this is the other one but this is what
he was in why so young
that girl was so hot I was friends she
looks like uh Jewish bronovich or the
Miss maisel uh maybe not
was he reading the manual
oh here we go no that's Jeremy Runners
I'm in a different one thought you said
you're in it with him we both we shot he
shot that when I shot mine the same day
he said he had just done this movie they
wouldn't or at least he had called
Dahmer independent movie when all these
independent Spirit Awards because he
won't release it I'm on [ __ ] sag
they're helping me out with my rent
because I can't pay my [ __ ] rent this
movie's kind of come out I don't know I
might do something about all these
Awards I didn't realize I didn't either
cool guy this is uh oh that was a hurry
yeah oh that was the old Ari he had the
hair and the beard
hey now is this after Amazing Racist
[Music]
yeah right at the same time oh man you
had a moment yeah this is after good to
have you back thanks
all right that's like the re that would
have been a rabbi yes I was shortly out
from that I couldn't feel how to put in
both worlds now where are we at on pay
because they commercials you to pay dude
that Kia commercial it's not up there I
guess but like
but like it gave me like 20 or 40 Grand
over like a two-year period which is
like you know you can make enough the
taxes on the shoot were the biggest
check I've ever seen how was the
audition
the easy I just got out of my car and
yelled my fake car you know like come to
mind my belly look at that well you had
a look I had a look that's most of it
can you pull up me in a Toyota
commercial no way yeah yeah Comedy
Central thing yeah I remember this I
think I made you know six grand on this
but still I remember you got that I was
like whoa it was huge they closed down
Brooklyn Bridge I got to drive across it
with a big uh oh this is it how did you
find this Salamanca is good
look how young I was fresh faced as me
working on bits fakely in a place you
can't afford
this is the whole gag is I'm driving
around and I see [ __ ] I'm like that's a
bit
like you would never be able to drive in
New York it's an LA thing yeah yeah
exactly old New York comedy club too
yeah that took two days wow that was a
nightmare yeah it was a nightmare what
was that Doritos one I remember Doritos
One commercial I don't remember dude
that's a big Edge special
all right oh today's episode of our
spirit
oh I remember this
maybe you go to somebody
all right
I was doing fake commercials to cover up
for the [ __ ] drug sponsors I had
always had I can't put that on YouTube
I'm kind of loving these sweatshirts
right now oh not bad at all
Matt Peters bringing the heat yeah
everything will be uh should we let them
in order and say the prayer I want to
hear it yeah yeah I'm going to be all
over the place but I know the words I
just don't know the order now here's the
quote would the defamation league go
after you guys if you said an offensive
joke or is that okay no they've gone
after me I was in the silence Center for
um hate speech once whoa really yeah
wait there's a center for hate speech
how do I get tickets
you got it let the shaunish first you
did it right
wait all right now do the prayer I Gotta
Know It wait wait wait you gotta say the
prayer first then you light it up you
got it you got it
yeah yeah so far
[Music]
yeah like we would know Hanukkah yeah
yeah that's the ending yeah there's
something else though
[Music]
alum
[Music]
I don't know it's a beautiful language
I'm a shitty Jew guys I'm sorry oh
you're doing pretty good it's been a
long time for me don't forget to watch
my special on YouTube right now yes wow
suck a Kanye yeah there we go how do you
remember that it's just just sounds
mixing up the order there no ouch
[Music]
five million that's for my hits
on YouTube
you got to do a party for six bills this
one's for the Jews that died we're even
now guys yes for the days we have to get
before we evict you and half of a candle
for Lenny Kravitz and eight is how long
the Jewish chicks periods are all right
great [ __ ] from Jewish chicks
here's why this is not real because a
chick singing it not in my community
it's messed up bro oh I had a great
moment on my connect flight today where
uh you know that you do they have to
gate check all the uh bags yeah and
doing that little thing where they they
pull down the thing they have to lift it
all the way up you either get it handed
to you the bag or you get the thing they
have to pull up like the garage door yes
this woman was we're all freaking out
because it's Atlanta we're trying to
make our connection all of us and it's
all these [ __ ] Midwestern people who
are too polite to say anything thank God
they got a New Yorker there but all the
people there like the woman's like I
can't get it open they're like all like
but I was like lady we got [ __ ]
connections yes come on and she was like
okay I'll call help and she called help
it's two of the women with like long
fingernails I'm like yeah this is gonna
help they come they can't figure it out
20 minutes of this so I'm like I might
miss my connection because they can't
figure out how to open a door I think
that they've used multiple times it's
not but it's their job it's a it's like
from the 80s we were talking about this
so then they call a guy I shoot you not
a guy shows up in a hat kicks it it just
opens Ponzi showed up yeah I was like
come on and you want to vote I'm like
guess what if the New Yorker doesn't
snap we don't make our flights yeah
there's a place for politeness yeah
that's true that ain't there that's a
good sketch a New Yorker in certain
areas New Yorker yeah whoever you are
it's like [ __ ] we're not getting
anything done you need to drive you
somewhere we're like yeah yeah okay Alec
Baldwin shows up he's like all right I'm
out of here some tuk-tuk drivers trying
to shake it down for some extra Thailand
bot I don't know New Yorkers like well I
know the price
we're good at confrontation yeah yeah
one of our only skills it's because
there aren't guns in the city
that's why we're good at confrontation
yeah that's true I do have a bit like
along those lines but that's not the bit
but but it's true that's why we are good
at conversations interesting so remember
some [ __ ] lady me Norman and list
seen an awful Casey Affleck movie about
a ghost Casey oh movie stars spent 95 of
the movie in a uh an actual sheet it was
so bad it was trying to be artsy
pretentious brutal worst 100 of Rotten
Tomatoes no no it's not pretty high up
pretty high Casey Affleck is a ghost and
Rooney's in it that girl Mara Rooney
Mara Rooney is it Rooney look at it look
at me he's in a [ __ ] ghost outfit
whoa I didn't know that that's him
that's Casey where do you use your actor
it looks like a parody could have done
this role
uh so bad Sundance get out of here get
the [ __ ] out of here this must be the
cheapest movie to shoot of all time 5.2
million views wow for this trailer a24
is a little bit on their own dick oh
yeah there's a little bit like you know
when they throw up the a24 film you
could just feel them being like yeah
we're [ __ ] a24 dude that's right
we'll do whatever we want but anyway
we're walking strolling eating some ice
cream and some ladies like like I should
try to get bias do you remember oh yeah
and somebody one of us was like what's
her problem we're all like she's gonna
die soon she's gonna [ __ ] Rush this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you man it was just
like uh why did I pick on Comics yeah
we're trying to make a movie here sister
yeah that movie's stuck I remember I
stole a bunch of beef jerks don't beef
jerky he took the highest level or
priced item I turned you bought some
popcorn five finger discount they serve
beef jerks what's one of these high-end
high-end a24 type theater
and we were the only people in there by
the way yeah as soon as she turned for
my popcorn snooky snitch yeah there used
to be a theater on the upper west side
it was like 61st Street or something and
they had cashews and it's like you know
you're getting some good movies yeah
they're serving cash you know you know
you're getting a [ __ ] foreign or what
an Woody Allen film right if you're
doing salted nuts at the concession I
need to get a nice snack the Angelica
used to serve quiche no joke I remember
that again yeah they might still do that
they might still yeah yeah I went there
on a hot date night in 2007 the quiche
was a hot part yeah it was warm to score
I think I did what did you say uh Juno
oh good movie yeah that's a winner Jason
reitman's got some [ __ ] winners yeah
he's good thank you for smoking there oh
yeah he's got some bangers dude
hmm
what is Ivan Ivan just passed away he
did he did what I don't know it's sudden
it was like 75 I met him I met Ivan uh I
did like I met with this company a long
time ago he was a nice guy Wow first
time I always came to the belly room one
bedroom that's right battle
yeah cool guy yeah he's a [ __ ] great
director [ __ ] yeah
I've been to Legend I mean Ghostbusters
Stripes that guy made so many class if
there was if there was a good comedy
with titties in the 80s that guy yes he
really used a titty he did yeah real
used one it was pre-porn yeah
pre-internet porn my tit was a big deal
yeah it wasn't skating by it he was
letting you see it it's funny because a
tit still hits like I was on a you know
we see tits all day long you put your
[ __ ] Instagram they almost showed
tits Twitter has tits but I was on an
airplane and I could see like eight
screens over a boob was on the screen I
was like
I could have put it on mine but the fact
that it was on someone else's was so hot
yeah it's a more forbidden test yes it's
a voyeur tit yeah and it's a public
place too it's a show me it's also for
your envoyeur it's like meta it's like a
meditate yeah a meta tits the best hits
yeah there's something about it he
directed izlo and Integris of Siberia
oh okay he produced he produced Heisler
Phillips career really he produced he
found Tom Phillips
because he was Todd
he did no I mean he found him and he
like I think he produced road trip which
was his first big whoa do you think your
presence in Joker
yeah I think he was teetering on the
edge and I I definitely yeah I
definitely helped I heard that theory
before it's called the Marilla effect oh
look at that fact
I didn't even just see a picture of
yourself you like [ __ ] kill me oh
yeah Sam Morel on his role and who who
yeah that's a YouTube for you
Sam's mom cut this
oh come on
what are you doing oh you can hear it
yeah
no but Todd if you think it's a musical
yeah I have got pipes you need someone
to sing luck be a lady I'm your guy it's
a musical [ __ ] me a lady tonight
they call you Lady Luck is that most
sizzlak yeah if you're doing the Muppets
movie Sam was there for you dude you got
that Muppet Babies theme song's been in
my head long and hard
I can't believe no Jews have reached out
because this is like you're I'm a little
break right I'm a little upset that no
Jews I've been off the grid for the last
10 days that's the problem people have
reached out and you haven't checked your
Instagram yeah maybe I'll ask Kyla and
you guys reach out because she's like I
don't know they all look like Jews to me
yeah well we got lucky because we got
Ari a day before he's gonna disappear to
Thailand or wherever the [ __ ] three
months he's gonna be gone like Rambo or
something where some general has to find
him in a hut
instead of a general with an assistant
from CAA who has to knock on the door
always meditating all right we have a
gig for you we're going to Beacon
there you go there's a banger in my day
dude no do you have the thing where
because you did a special a couple
months ago you just had one out now yeah
right now and now you gotta go you're
gonna sell some tickets off the back of
this thing you gotta have a new you
gotta have a new [ __ ] I was very lucky
this time
cause the Lakers came after me pretty
hard so I had to stop doing this hour
for a little while oh I already worked
on another hour right plus it's still so
long building this one all my leftover
material all the [ __ ] that was like by
the Lakers dude who do you mean
because I just picture like you know
John Sally yeah yeah
you know
literally Vlade yeah
um
yeah so I know I'll plus I had leftover
material like I need like a weird like I
got a dog it's like it doesn't fit in
the Jew hour but like I still do bits
about it so I had like leftover jokes I
was already ready to go so that was no
problem I'll talk to Schultz about it it
is annoying he finished especially like
oh [ __ ] my boys in Fort Wayne well you
built I I've got like a new 50 that's
passable I can get by with like 50. well
it's not like special worthy but I can
get by it's sellable worthy yeah it's
it's getting last you can you can you
can morally charge a crowd yeah it's
hitting all the way through it just
needs it needs to be better to put be
put in a special so I'm gonna take my
time with this next one yeah yeah you
know what I'm gonna do because I did it
this time where I stopped whatever put
it away went on [ __ ] holiday for you
know covet and then whatever else and
then did other material and then I was
like all right let me try to do this
[ __ ] special so then I started doing
it again for eight months or so
but then I left it for like a year and I
was like damn I could [ __ ] tighten
all these bits I saw it like fresh again
you know you guys are better joke
writers than I am but like
but like I could see it from the outside
going damn that's too long a setup these
two jokes are almost exactly the same
right what's your process with that when
you listen to bits like how do you how
do you cut the fat and how do you like I
have trouble with it cutting the facts
I'm like this is good this is great this
is great this is good I'm like well good
and better I want to keep it in but you
got to be like nah the Good's not that
good
yeah sometimes there's a line for you
that's the problem sometimes there's a
line for you that like you want to walk
that line between being indulgent
because there's bits where like I'm like
almost cut and it turns out to be
someone's favorite wine well yeah when I
was doing this not happening anything I
was like you know showed the comics like
like the comment section wouldn't let me
but I just did it anyway where I was
like hey what do you tell me your notes
on this I'll pretend like they're my
notes and so I sent one to Mark and I
was like I'm gonna cut this line this
line tell me what you think and Mark's
like no no that's like a catchphrase of
mine I want to keep that in
[Laughter]
you know you know out of all the shows
we've done no one more Hands-On with the
editing than you that was pretty great I
don't know if you guys can you fought
for Comics
like I mean the Doug Smith set which I
think is uh
cats too yeah yeah I'd go down to the
New York club so many times to watch
Doug dude I was like hold on I got 10
minutes I'll go who's doing that by the
way that's insane that's very cool yeah
like what's your show I mean you wanted
you took pride in your show I think
that's yeah it came with another way to
lie to get New York comics in be like we
don't have the money to fly people in
it's first class and we need to put them
in a hotel we just don't have the budget
for that I was like what if they were
just here randomly like well I'm a good
book I was locals I'm like
I'll talk to you guys look at that yeah
he made it happen I booked Norman that
way I booked big J that way I booked
Norman that way and the Norman's agent
called and was like Hey where's this
offer what about the hotel what about
what about the the flight and I was like
talk to your client I think he's going
to be in La anyway yes I stayed on some
Miguel's couch you can get here I can
get you on but I can't get you here yeah
that's what the offer said marks Mark
said Mark's plowing he's plowing this
[ __ ]
it's plow contingent look up your makeup
Lady by the way on that show you hooked
up with her yeah yeah I remember damn oh
yeah old blonde did you regret it once
the makeup came off the black face
there huh I got a number but it was uh I
called it was it went
it was a payphone seven digit number
here
hookers strippers and Comics we have a
kinship if we do yeah there's a weird I
mean there's something about like you
know putting yourself in front of people
right vulnerable it's gonna be rough bad
childhood yeah parents are disappointed
in you yeah the good shows is bad
although Comics can turn it around
Thomas will turn around the higher up
you get in the strip World it could get
worse it is true you don't want to be a
world renowned stripper yeah but I guess
that's kind of the goal I guess yeah I
guess so but it's not going to turn
around
I think it's Comics almost like pis like
those old books right Comics are like
[ __ ] uh
waiting for the phone to ring right yeah
weird hours you're going to weird places
you went on a check to clear yeah it's
like more like a pi situation hungover
pizza boxes yeah you go to a diner and
we follow
up yeah three days
you made it vinyl for same time tomorrow
I didn't make it someone sent it in
someone made it or just no this is all
stuff from our listeners we don't I
don't know that's not a working vinyl no
oh I don't know that I think I made a
vinyl for out to lunch and they'd sold
like hotcakes yeah I gotta make a bottle
for Jew I can give you guys the info it
do that you got it I didn't do a I just
promoted it the the company ships it
they give you the money I love that out
to lunch album money part uh-oh uh oh oh
God I don't know what that is 25 finals
are the Best Buy for if you're going to
see a band best value buy it's like 25
30 bucks same price as a t-shirt for
[ __ ] ever you sell t-shirts on the
road are you no I used to I just I need
like 30 minutes to calm down after I get
off stage I know what you mean what
about like didn't you used to sell those
weed Grinders that was a great for your
fan base it was a great it was per Ed
Brooke was like why don't you just saw
some weed roulette I told them a story
of me in Toronto before I was famous but
like an occasional recognized and
somebody's like are you always your fear
and I was like yeah he goes can I smoke
a joint with you I'm like have you got
one and he's like let's do it smoke
three heads and he's like keep it let's
go I told everyone that goes you gotta
start selling some weed [ __ ] yeah it's a
[ __ ] hilarious agent yeah
you gotta lean into this drug [ __ ] he's
the least agent agent
he's a good dude he was telling me once
I was I was like getting I don't know I
was like flying with we go sorry if you
get caught with weed and you miss your
[ __ ] gigs in Minneapolis this is a
long time ago it's gonna hold you back
no one's going to want to book you if
you suddenly get an arrest and can't do
a [ __ ] show it's not good for your
career I'm like what if I get like big
like Doug Benson like won't it
eventually help me goes we'll get to
that stage from here and then at some
point like years later I was like hey
man if I get arrested for weed now it
would be cool I would help my draw right
he goes yes
do you think the Kobe thing obviously
the the initial shock was bad but do you
think
it kind of
helped a little in the end because it
was a huge Splash yeah yeah when I got
when I got during covet I think these
black kids were like hey all right and I
was like uh oh it's like there's like 24
year olds like hey can we get a picture
okay and they're like Kobe and then I
was like oh I think I'm the guy who like
trust goes for it doesn't worry about
his own safety that's funny you say that
because I remember hanging out with
Gillis after that the whole thing
happened all these Asian guys like we
gotta get a photo and they just love
sending that photo my old roommate Dory
Asian guy [ __ ] loves Skillets there
you go I think he's my favorite comic
and I saw him go over Gillis and tell
him I guess you get was like turn to me
you're like
uh I remember when Ari after the Kobe
thing we were at the stand and our and I
was like I'm going to The Cellar now
he's like I'll go with you and I was
like walk like a cab
I don't want to walk there sorry Sam's
Sam's reaction was that was one of the
best Dorman went hard on me towards
before me but like um but Sam they came
after Comics like disowned Ari it was so
weird and you're like what do you think
about Ari and he goes oh he's consistent
he just pretty much I love her I'm not
getting involved with this I don't know
he's made the Lakers for a while I love
Kobe I was a basketball fan but always
my actual friend
you know it's great those reports I
opened it was opening for Hannibal after
the Cosby thing broke and he was like no
no enough leave me alone it's too much
like we'll give you 10 grand for five
minute interview he's like no leave me
alone wow for the women's at the Cosby
too he didn't listen yeah 10 grand leave
me alone but yeah so they they want on
it yeah I think overall like increased
my [ __ ] and
who I am damn that's a pretty good D you
got there thanks buddy you want to fill
me up what are you doing yeah what is
that oh there we go yeah wow that feels
all right I'm just dip your face in it
for a sec let's see what oh yeah wait
give me Morty board give me that one
motorboat for your age they feel great
look at that damn all right look at that
look I just passed out of the bar no big
deal oh what oh my god oh yeah yeah that
brought me right back to my childhood
this is this is Mark's mom
actually matters nothing like that no oh
she's lovely lovely parents the wedding
was so great actually talked about it
I mean that gas stationary
oh the star Bros uh [ __ ] Morel
shaffir disgust out by the way we're
eating we're eating all this fried food
in the hotel lobby and Ari just dips he
made us feel so [ __ ] cheap he
went upstairs we did but Ari just
[ __ ] finishes his hero and he just
runs away and we're like what the [ __ ] I
felt like he just nutted enough I called
ran out I called it Uber six bites out I
was like it'll be all right at the right
time and then we're like I won't finish
by was it any good it was great it was
great but it was disco I mean it was
like great disgusting we were eating
fried seafood but if you're gonna do
that do it in a New Orleans gas station
yeah Sam got the split skis like a
[ __ ] boyfriend girlfriend combo that
was hot we looked at each other we both
knew it who would be the first to break
the silence I want to know what it is
because we couldn't decide and then it's
good when you can split with it first
yeah I'm not gonna throw something out
to you and you're like I'm already ahead
of you yeah yes because we could decide
between fried oysters and soft shell
crab and I was like what if we split
and then stov is like literally calling
the dream what he was calling us rookies
what did he order he ordered the thing
to get that wasn't on them
uh and he was he were you on the phone
he waited until 30. should I ordered
first what he got like a po boy to go he
got like on the flight back he had to
just finish another po boy Liz from the
seller sees him covered in mayonnaise
what you're disgusting if that guy
doesn't be careful he's gonna get fat
I like the picture stop I was walking in
and going the guy's like freak catfish I
know you I've heard him yeah he's like
norm and cheers the Highlight was when I
when I was [ __ ] wrecked just saying
man imagine eating this [ __ ] sober and
stuff goes I haven't had one drink oh
man he can hang I mean what a fun hang
When You're Sober everybody's drunk it's
hard but he he doesn't budge he doesn't
Flinch he doesn't right he's not like
worried about it at all it sucks to be
with a shaky sober alcoholic yes those
are no fun yes and they're judging you
gotta be able to spit wine in someone's
face
yeah no we definitely that was a fun
wedding that was yeah it was mad fun I
mean and that second night too I mean uh
[ __ ] no it was a great picture of Ari
and stuff what Ari just looks [ __ ] oh
God
that's the closer on my dude May so we
get to the bar after the wedding look at
it oh yeah yeah we get to the bar after
the wedding whatever bar that was our
bar bar yeah May and our mushrooms it
was also very interesting because
there's two separate
um ages of comedy at that wedding yeah
it's a bunch of Headliners and a bunch
of openers yeah so it's like oh hey like
like I don't know I know everybody or no
some of them
anyway so may and her openers they're
like all right all right come here come
here and I'm I mean [ __ ] up and uh and
she goes uh and she goes uh hey we have
these mushroom chocolate bars
can you uh pass these out
oh that's fun I was like okay there it
is oh that's yeah that was my closer on
the Reel that looks like the cover of
like a buddy comedy yes that's like the
new Harold and Kumar but uh are we and
stuff yeah
right uh go to po boy Central or
something it's two uh New Orleans
detectives we got Mardi Gras and boudin
so yeah that left eye is left oh yeah
Good Times where was I talking about Tom
is so [ __ ] fun oh yeah he really is
he's just the best
all right so she gives me this chocolate
box four big chocolate bars oh yeah all
right hand them out so I just find one
guy I go with the [ __ ] glass you're
doing a line off his [ __ ] I'm literally
like about to stop stuffing your head
down I'm trying to stuff it down with
him mainly making his 10 minute
appearance yeah I know right what a diva
I handed one chocolate bottle to one guy
found somebody else like hey mushroom
chocolate bars sure then to a third guy
and then what have made his friends like
oh no no break it up pieces yeah I'm
already on mushrooms why did your hand
what'd you give me this responsibility
with a shaman I guess so but [ __ ]
talk to me you are kind of weirdly
trustworthy with [ __ ] like that as I'm
19.20 times the perfect doser yeah yeah
well the 20s was burnt yeah
and I will say I got the right amount in
them
I saw bird then I can vouch she had a
[ __ ] ball yeah he was having a great
time he was having a great time yeah he
was fine I mean I didn't know he had
dinner with his kids and had a flight at
six a.m but he had a great time yeah
serve you all the drinks with napkins on
top
that was enough you had a good domino of
uh scandalous [ __ ] yeah yeah but you've
cleaned it up it's cleaned it up about
Hanukkah I'm a Jew a ReDiscover religion
watch my special orange Fair Jew on
YouTube right now yeah yeah but people
don't realize it's a dark side you know
you're you're the fun guy you're the go
for it guy you're the Dosey guy dosey
doe he's all the fun I like these are
the fun sides yeah but
but there is the guilt where people go
what are you crazy and you have to go am
I and they go are you a bad person you
go am I so it's like we said with
Hemingway sure he was a fist fight and
whiskey slurping gun toting shot himself
but I'm sure he was had some mornings
where he's like I gotta clean it up I
get anxiety over anxiety like a mother
dude I did sober October and I never
felt less anxiety really I was like I'm
free I thought it was the weed I talked
to bertho and he was like no I'm I don't
I feel nothing too it might be the Boost
oh booze is bad this is great who would
have thought that alcohol is Bird's
problem that's crazy I thought it was
sure I would have thought
no it's I get hangover anxiety I get it
before I go to bed like I definitely had
a few too many last night because I was
you know I'm in Fort Wayne Indiana and
it's Sunday what are you doing weekend
going to bed before his flight no way I
had a bunch of glasses of wine in the
green room and I'm like you know I'm
[ __ ] and then I'm up late at night
like [ __ ] I'm anxious yeah I get that
video hey [ __ ]
when you want a smooth high that you
know is made right here in the U.S of a
look no further an ounce of Hope based
out of Memphis Tennessee uh
ounce of Hope is your One-Stop shop for
Delta eight Delta 9 and CBD Edibles oils
and more I use this stuff every night
literally to go to sleep I love it it's
not too high you don't want to go into
some edible coma where you can't see
straight you don't know when you're
gonna die and you're panicking anytime
the phone rings this stuff is just the
right amount it's just perfect it helps
me sleep better harnessing the power of
aquaponics
ounce of Hope is the farm to table brand
for getting high aquaponics combines
fish and plant farming so all the
nutrients released by The Fish make an
extremely healthy plan ah you're getting
high thanks to fish [ __ ] visit
ounceofhope.com and use drunk for 20 off
your first order that's
o-u-n-c-e-o-f-h-o-p-e.com
[Music]
with promo code drunk and start saving
on the best Delta 8 and Delta 9 products
here it is
we might be drunk It's brought to you by
bespokes posts box of awesome is easy to
remember because every time you open one
you just think awesome bespoke post
partners with small business and
emerging brands that bring you the most
unique Goods every month from cozy
Essentials to cocktail kits box of
awesome has everything you need for
winter we love these guys they're
sending over a cast box we got it right
here whoa personal sized aging barrel
for your favorite cocktail holy look at
that beard you wow we can make our own
stuff if only we had our own whiskey
just take the quiz at boxofawesome.com
and they'll pick the right box of
awesome for you you only pay a fraction
of what these boxes are worth Plus 90 of
everything in your box is from a small
up and coming brand like Bodega cat and
bubble wrap
can't go wrong it's free to sign up and
you can skip a month or cancel any time
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com and
enter the code drunk at checkout
never fails that's box of awesome.com
code drunk for 20 off your first box box
of awesome.com promo code drunk
we might be drunk is brought to you by
rocket money most Americans think they
spend about eighty dollars a month on
subscriptions when the actual total cost
is closer to 200 grams
you could be wasting a hundred dollars
each month on subscriptions you don't
even know about that's why we love
rocket money formerly known as true bill
the app shows all your subscriptions in
one place and cancels whatever ones you
don't want rocket money can even find
subscriptions you didn't know you were
paying for wow
you may even find out you've been double
charged for a subscription holy hell
they're raping you to cancel a
subscription just press cancel and
Rocket money will take care of the rest
easy peasy get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to rocketmoney.com drunk
seriously you could save hundreds per
year that's
rocketmoney.com
drunkard cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com
slash drunk get on it did you guys get
party buses in high school no you know
we did a couple it was just a BJ Fest it
was great on the bus on the bus girls
didn't know what to do so they're like I
didn't know what to do
well you're just the tall seats so you
can't really should I do you can't
really dance should we have a
conversation yeah we should just suck
everyone off right you're running things
to talk about so we gotta get this party
bus yeah it's just us four in the town
sucking each other's dicks
I got Syracuse oh [ __ ]
it's just it's just coming on each
other's faces everyone's like this is
the worst episode of we might be drunk
yeah
what were we supposed to do talk yeah on
a podcast we blew each other
we sucked each other's dicks oh I'm
actually like actually it was weirdly I
was excited in the cab from the airport
to come here yeah because it's like I'll
see you've just been on the road alone
yes no idea we saw movies we had fun but
you know we uh no I'm coming from the
airport it's a connect flight I'm tired
I know I knew booze would put me in a
better mood I knew seeing friends would
put me in a better mood it's like you
know it is to always come back go right
to the comedy store and just like
rejuvenated yeah I'm at the cellar right
after this I managed to take my [ __ ]
luggage but oh yeah what are you gonna
do winter move oh is that it
so you gotta carry on with the uh the
the side bag yeah nice laptop in the
side bag oh you gotta have the laptop oh
yeah since the show is bottomed out let
me ask you hey guys
God damn it doing a Tumi review here
yeah I got some bits you guys got bits I
got a jupit I wrote for you guys I'd
like to run it by I think you're gonna
hate it okay oh yeah all right so you
know with the anti-Semitism bubbling up
I've been uh my media I've been talking
about the way until Mark starts every
conversation
so I've been talking to some people and
one guy was like oh these Jews come on
they're acting like babies it's no big
deal they're acting like babies and I
was like I don't know I think it's you
know whatever but I do think however
babies are acting like Jews I was at a
diner with a friend and he was Jewish or
he's Jewish and there was a baby a table
over and they were doing the same [ __ ]
you know they bought that little hats on
the baby spit up my friend got
indigestion and I could do eight
examples and then the bill came and they
both started crying all right is so
funny Jews don't cry when the bill comes
up until then it's funny I think oh
what's it said I think it works how
about the bill came and they both pooped
their pants and made an excuse to leave
yeah I like that better really yeah okay
okay they both moved their pants to try
to get out of it yeah and make no
mistake these babies will replace us I
know I would say I would I would I would
I would say that the babies both went to
the bathroom and try to get out of it oh
that's good that's what that's gonna do
okay there we go it's a hard time that's
a funny bathroom they faked are you
ready to have me laughing when you said
babies or like shoes because I defend
the Jews and I do I do all right I'll
try it I like it I had one that was
tried last night that hit is new but I
think there's maybe more here about like
sex robots how everyone's gonna have sex
robots in the future we're going on all
these dates you go on the dates and the
and and then you're like well in the
future we won't go on days because we'll
just like I mean you get lazy when you
jack off think about when you have a sex
robot even poor people have sex robots
in the future right you you'll have the
high-end ones it's like Spotify Premium
then you have the shitty ones that's
like they you get mad every once in a
while you're [ __ ] it you're [ __ ] a
sex robot like right as you're gonna
come it's gonna be like liberty liberty
liberty
there's something there though yeah
that's funny the ads during sex is great
ads during sex yeah you should get a
Casper your bed sucks
you call this a bed yeah yeah all right
early ad for uh I think sofa matches one
of those places
Segura got it for everybody he was like
they're giving money out for ads do an
ad read and I did one it was all about
how [ __ ] Christina straps a strap-on
on and [ __ ] Tom in the ass and [ __ ]
and makes them bleed and just he's
crying but his knees are very soft on
the softer mattress and and I mean they
loved it everybody loved it sofa was
like no
[Laughter]
absolutely not take that down who was
that who said we need an ad but you can
use anybody but Ari did you hear about
that yeah who was that Chuck told me who
was it blue too blue chew was like hey
we need an ad done I'm gonna go ahead
and say this shame on Bluetooth we're
having an ego your dick they came around
though they came around they uh they
said hey do you want to do a sponsor I
was like wait what I was the name you
couldn't use but why are you I mean they
didn't say Harvey Weinstein they said
Ari I did an ad for it I don't think
they're doing ads with Harvey either
well he could use it I didn't ask for my
skeptic thing it was an episode about
dogs I mean Adrian and I was like for
Bluetooth like let's say you want to
[ __ ] your dog but you're not
you're not a truck you're not a [ __ ]
pedophile
here's the thing though you are still
endorsing that their product works
that's what I was saying
I'm just saying if you want a good ad
all right he's gonna get you there yeah
point and then they were like No And I
was like all right we're done all right
all right so what's the bit uh how about
this
only done it a couple times but I don't
know if it'll work yet
pill
you know how you say your friends keep
you in check you're a little correct but
I don't think that's true your friends
rarely ever give you real advice and say
like hey what are you doing that girl
sucks for you or whatever it's a pill
that turns you temporarily autistic and
allows you to have no shame and say
whatever you want to anybody I think
I've taken
you gotta take the antidote wait a
minute why why would you want to do that
your breath smells I don't like it oh
and they go what the hell man you go oh
I took the grill oh right back I'm sorry
I'm on something yeah ah you can do
better by the way they haven't they have
that already we're drinking it okay
you can pause and be like actually you
know what a joke I just invented alcohol
yeah I'll do by the way I'll do another
if we're still rocking I don't know I
just gotta top off retardle
all right all right
a pill that makes you autistic
temporarily it's always like a truth
serum yeah truth that's I think I have
no shame suddenly you're just like just
do whatever you want to do don't feel
bad about anything
interesting and you can hit three
pointers
[ __ ] nail those threes you can also
do your taxes yeah just knock it out
because you're autistic
that's not bad all right all right what
about peeves do we have peeves anyone oh
I forgot [ __ ] I just had to pee my head
from last night I got one all right I
just noticed this
just come back I was in Mexico City for
Thanksgiving
Mexico and Mexico City man you get
around to get around
notice this you love Mexico City great
town right I've never been to Mexico
really I should go Roman Norte like yeah
yeah Roma
North Rome
um
as soon as we land
yeah
what the [ __ ] I know a little Spanish
[ __ ]
as soon as we land we haven't even got
to the gate yet the they start standing
up opening up the [ __ ] what's it
called overheads yeah and like guys sit
down we're not at the gate we're not
even like there but not docked we're not
even there we're still moving yeah they
sit down and they immediately start
standing back up it's like guys stop
we're not there yet
notice the same [ __ ] thank you uh going
to Dominican Republic
um I asked uh Jesus Trejo about it he
said it's a Latino thing ah those
Latinos don't trust their stuff with
white people so I get it immediately
what are we gonna do I don't know all
right it's a weird stereotype about
whites I guess interesting yeah yeah
sit down it's a piece sit down a bunch
of people a bunch of honkies tried to
move to Mexico City during the pandemic
and there were so many of them that they
gave uh Whitey a 10-day allowance what
do you mean like you can't live here you
can you can come here for 10 days and
visit and do the [ __ ] but you can't
hear what they said about they said
they're gonna build a wall and they're
gonna make us pay for it they're not
happy about the Americans coming no a
lot of Americans in Mexico City now in
Roma and in um in LA condessa and
they're like what they're driving on
Chrome prices yeah back up to [ __ ]
normal prices so I'm [ __ ] because the
lady I was counting her on the wedding I
was like you did a great job on the
wedding and she was like yeah maybe I
got a knack for event planning and I was
like yeah please never done it no and so
she goes maybe for your 40th I'll have a
big party and I was like no I don't want
to party I hate a party I don't want to
be in the center of the party I've
already married your list I know I'm
like I don't want to party Joe so I said
I want to go to Mexico City I've never
been she goes all right we'll do that
what do a party there no just go I just
want to go there I'd rather go somewhere
than have a party what
she had well she'll plan it kayako
planet
well I'm married to the woman I should
break her oh May yes Oh I thought you
meant the event planner no no I was like
damn I always kind of callous I don't
know
yeah man I I got to do a vacation again
at some point I don't do that [ __ ] I
gotta really you need a girlfriend I
know I went on one alone and then I do I
went there for one night and I texted my
friend Chase I was like get the [ __ ] up
here and he came here we did it together
it was actually really fun we had a
great time dude we go with a friend it's
kind of fun it helps they're gonna make
a group trip to Iceland this this summer
whoa Iceland's beautiful I have is that
what you've heard yeah I've heard it's
[ __ ] incredible especially in the
summer yeah I heard it's weak I heard
everybody kills themselves those Nordic
areas no that's Syracuse New York
got it same weather uh yeah but there's
a lot of suicide up there because
there's no sun in this in the winter
yeah but the Summer's supposed to be
beautiful oh okay yeah it's great and a
cheap flight out here you can do
stopovers in the way to whatever free
stopover as long as you want on
Icelandic Air if you want to see England
or the Glasgow whatever
um you could just be like layover in
Iceland and then like stay here for five
six days in your layover what no extra
cost wow wow there have you been there
yeah three times you're a [ __ ]
traveler man your passport must be just
covered in stands yeah there's a new
country and uh what you have to sew in
extra pages no but I'd love to I want to
make a wallpaper out of all the stamps
oh that's good yeah what's coming out
Hanukkah guess where I'll be right I
guess where I am right now where
Guatemala damn yeah leaving my phone at
home leaving my computer at home
it's interesting like we're so
nervous and not that way take some buses
you are like the Rambling Man of Comedy
you're like I just picture you without a
shirt on just like walking to a desert
yeah Lawrence of Arabia or some [ __ ]
walking stick get your shirt around your
head tied up I just picture Ari like
Moses yeah
always the most biblical comedian huh
[Laughter]
no but I'm thinking about it who are you
with
we have to talk about this on air this
is like an off-air conversation I think
but uh you know I'm with them with
William Brothers okay they have a they
have a they'll figure it out yeah yeah
yeah I'm planning mine for April May oh
wow yeah going with your girl
who's April
April Macy and me good for you yeah
you're so fun have you you've never you
did it with burp you've never done your
own thing I did London you should do it
and that was awesome I'm trying to I
lost for recommendations it goes go to
Estonia go to Slovenia wow oh the couple
like off the race Estonia is like the
weak country in NATO that's like the one
we're kind of babysitting you know oh
really yeah something like that we're
like yeah we have them for [ __ ] you
know namesake we're like it's another
name good name for a weed fight Estonia
all right but yeah Estonia
Louie says right we have jumped the
shark on this episode
it's Dr Pepper whatever the [ __ ] we're
drinking is so good these are for sure
good
no no I mean I'm [ __ ] I've got a nice
little buzz on right now oh yeah Estonia
by the way fastest internet connection
besides South Korea in the world look at
all Factory over here
why is
that's all they got
well I'm just saying anytime sales [ __ ]
anytime you go to work really fast they
tell you they're what they have like
when I went to Fort Wayne like you know
we invented the sewing machine I'm like
that's it I just got off the plane how
about nice restaurant what's a good uh
bar sewing machine guess what they make
clothes [ __ ] everywhere I know also
they were bragging me they didn't work
out they have the big microphone thing
they have a big microphone uh Company in
Fort Wayne I'm like the mic went out on
me three straight shows
I have two long stories in my set every
time it went out it was in the middle of
a long story wow building the [ __ ]
momentum wow and I was like you guys
[ __ ] kidding me and it wasn't the
club's fault it was this goddamn camera
guy who was trying to connect the thing
and he was like I got you and I was like
you don't connect to the [ __ ] thing
again and he was like I won't and I was
like you did you [ __ ] did well you
got Arthur running the camera over here
this guy's a lush
I am so sorry I too much to drink you're
a prostitute I thought I was just doing
very well with you that's pretty good
I've seen that movie so many [ __ ]
times definitely more well we haven't
seen that movie that's a [ __ ]
old-timer you talk about the Russell
Brand version yeah no no no no yeah who
wanted to redo that movie I know right
it's like when I heard they were going
to redo back to school I'm like dude
who's popping Rodney who's doing Rob
yeah the other guy the son anybody could
do that well yeah he was a young Downey
Jr though in that time that's pretty fun
so we're down in junior in it he's the
son's friend the weird you know artsy
friend and then you got Bert young I
love Downey Jr before he burned out oh
yeah pretty good right Lesson Zero yeah
lesson zeros a pitch of a beer every
seven minutes until someone passes out
don't bring this one every ten all right
all right Sam's got two Impressions and
you saw both you're all right you're all
right
I got this album
and this one
oh play this this is classic classic uh
nice pop-up salad Goose you know what
you're watching oh my God hey sexy yeah
what is this college you're a bad boy
Matt
oh man oh my God
good girth on that guy that guy's girth
was off the charts be happy about it
yeah yeah she looked in a mood huh yeah
yeah
we're drinking hard whiskey brother I
catch up on you
oh here we are this is one of the great
soundtracks too
and Jerry's dad
oh yes Jerry Stiller he's dead no no no
Jerry Seinfeld's Dead really yeah the
guy who plays Jerry's dead in Seinfeld
it's not Jerry oh I see I see
all right well great movie folks check
it out that's a [ __ ] old-timer some
old New York shots too oh Eliza
Minnelli's [ __ ] great in that movie
it's a classic I didn't realize where
Stacy was married to her toy recently
yeah
you know they used to play Liza Minnelli
version of um uh New York New York
um when the Yankees lost and Sinatra's
version when they won Eminem which is
always she heard and complained what
yeah that's fair what sort of you want
to be associated with losing I guess but
then just don't play the song when you
lose just don't play the song they gotta
walk out to something they gotta leave
to something do something else
play [ __ ] Jay-Z I don't know man but
you can't play the same song for a win
or a loss there's no there's nothing to
it there's something magical about
walking out of Yankee Stadium you can't
do to New York New York though that is
the
I think they should play a win or loss
they should play Sinatra that makes
sense to me now watch New York New York
recently it's like 1977. yeah and the
whole movie is like uh De Niro and
Minelli she wants to be a singer and he
wants to just you know be a writer it's
basically La La Land ah and he's like I
want to stay true to be a jazz musician
and the whole time he's like composing
New York New York the song
and I'm like watching him compose it and
watching her like write the lyrics I'm
like this is so right I know what's
going to happen the song's gonna be
great the truth is that song wasn't a
song before that movie oh really yeah
they wrote it no they wrote it for that
movie no that's amazing I didn't know
that hit in 1980 when Sinatra sang it
later wow well wait is it it's the same
song though yeah same song how bad is
hers that they play out on the losing
well imagine Sinatra's version sung by
lazy Minnelli
[ __ ] her I mean she's famous right for
singing who's singing yeah yeah no she's
good she's like hey we just brought in
some gay fans with Mateo and uh Fortune
themes so don't push them all away
all right now they're like what the [ __ ]
that's a chance we're getting everybody
we've got Jewish fans now this is good
God [ __ ] you oh yeah sorry piece of [ __ ]
well they heard your prayer
I tried
guys in this silence don't forget to
watch your video on YouTube right now
almost probably over 5 million views
right now yeah even if you're
anti-semitic just put it on and let it
play you guys are six million put it on
would you remind everyone of the [ __ ]
greatest story in Jewish history well
hopefully because when when yours ends
it rolls over to mine and vice versa
hopefully you'll get in the mix I think
I go to Shane's oh all right well there
you go yeah mine goes right to it but
yeah there'll be a mix of like a YouTube
comments yeah
uh this this is what they should play
with no Yankees lose
this is a bummer
yikes should I start to get the
anti-Semitism some guy walking out and
he goes you call that a [ __ ] swing
Stanton
I just see some kid lighting these
candles
[Laughter]
I'm picturing the lady in Schindler's
List the girl goodbye juice
that's a great joke great joke how do we
miss that one
try it again okay hold on man Spielberg
here's another wreck Spielberg on NPR
fresh air oh you read his new movie uh
the Fable men's yeah he does he does a
rare interview he doesn't do a lot of
interviews Spielberg he's just talking
movies and you're like man his life is
so [ __ ] interesting he's like I mean
he's American royalty oh yeah like you
think of the movies he's made like Jaws
he knows nothing about him exactly and
Jaws is [ __ ] we're talking about like
Blockbusters like thing about what
Blockbusters are now Avatar is [ __ ]
trash Jaws is a great movie 18 years ago
15 years ago they're making a second and
they spent two billion dollars two
billion
I feel like was the Blockbuster maybe
it's because I was a kid well Jaws was
the first summer blockbuster and it's
his first movie isn't that insane really
well he came up with like Lucas and they
were like it was like Star Wars and Jaws
yeah
Indiana Jones well they that's where
they came together right right that's
when they met it's like a young sagalog
on my Canon
I would say you know dark is like one of
the coolest [ __ ] movies they were
trying to make like the shittiest action
movie they can make and they ended up
with is that right yeah they was like
they were just like okay what is like
the basis the lowest thing that we can
write
and they ended up with Raiders it's
great college professor turns our you
know uh archaeologist and the [ __ ]
shows how how far a score will take you
like Star Wars and Indiana Jones like
you hear those songs Forever John
Williams iconic
[Music]
yeah
yeah he's the ball don't forget he's one
cool [ __ ] never mind Back to the
Future that's not Spielberg that's not
her support either no that's uh Mecca
zemeck is also great he did that and and
um [ __ ] retardo Forrest Gump
yeah Benjamin buttons which is exactly
like no that was David Fincher yeah what
yeah
all the same right same writer sorry
same right all right good save Wario
next try bro all right we went in the
movie land we're nerds yeah movies we
drank this episode in the last seven
episodes this is a good [ __ ] app
though I do like hanging out with you
guys yeah Alex is great you can tell I'm
getting drunker because I keep
eyeballing that butane fuel
so
explodes yeah
this endorsement we had the sparklers
yeah they had every line up and then
Mark goes through it you know like a
[ __ ] uh horror and uh easy she's my
wife we're lighting up but there's some
drugs there oh and we're waiting we all
would dip it in [ __ ] alcohol and then
we're just waiting and there's a girl's
like this like whatever they're like all
right let your [ __ ] thanks and she's
like all right let's try to hold it she
keeps trying to like hit people with it
she's like you barely hold it right
waiting for you guys to come out people
like watch it she goes I am watching it
damn I didn't know that I definitely got
cornered by a few marks like drunken
childhood friends at the end of the
night you know the holy [ __ ] if I got
married they would be Corner my friends
would be cornering Mark oh yeah you know
what I mean I saw the photos and you can
see them they're like and you're like
oh my God where's Stavros that was just
Jason Cantor but
yeah my childhood friends they literally
I was at this The Altar and I look at my
phone because I'm I got there a little
early and one guy goes don't get married
yet in an Uber and I'm like That's a
classic text from a childhood friend
right there that is a great picture stop
just stuffing Ari's face anyways but
we're such [ __ ] degenerate
degenerates and by the way that [ __ ]
tasted great Greek yeah it tastes like
Tzatziki
wow I have no memory of this at all
memory boy that might have been the
ugliest group at the wedding right there
Jesus Christ what a lineup
whoa list a big J had the best line big
j i goes uh man I heard you got married
at Joe list concert
damn that's hilarious Joe [ __ ] rules
on the [ __ ] money that was so good
sober guy kill him and he's like I don't
know
just right in by the way Sally yeah we
paid a douche to take photos which I
regret I still haven't gotten his wow
he's like I'm happy what you did yeah
pull up some more of those pictures
they're [ __ ] incredible man what the
hell oh that's a great one oh wow that's
our bar
yeah
[Music]
that's not fun there's her dad Hey
That's a classic that is a great is that
the um is that the walk around the block
second line you can see the horse manure
right there
oh oh we got some liver spots coming in
hello there where did that come from
well a leopard wow that's your John
Goodman Lebowski sunglasses yeah yeah
no Donny
will so Vince's Donnie hmm well that's
what he really is that's all right
insane outfits that's the post that's a
picture to post when jolist dies like we
were friends
I think he might Outlast US based on the
path we're all on well he has McDonald's
three times a day yeah he told me he
actually texted me recently he was like
yeah I went to the doctor and some some
of my health is not good I was like gee
it wouldn't have anything to do with the
fact that you eat chicken parm with
chicken parm two cigars yeah yeah and a
Diet you think a [ __ ] one green tea a
day is saving you from all the [ __ ]
degenerate [ __ ] you're putting in your
body good point
oh that's a great action show I wonder
what's going on there yeah the insodes
he's calling you Jew and you're saying
that's the name of my special
good times what a [ __ ] fun town to do
this in no aren't you glad
all these photos and you weren't there
no offense everybody else in the room
but you'd be like ah come on we missed
it oh that's a that's a divorce coming
right there
that picture I'm sorry I left the baby
in the car
I thought I rolled the window down
that background is so good that that
wallpaper Peters are we gonna show these
pictures during the Pod can you yeah why
not yeah yeah that's a good one let's
see you pull that one is it
I love the Velvet jacket Mark oh thank
you that was my answer right after
ceremony Jack my shoes my feet were
killing me I got Band-Aids on my feet
Tarantino's gonna love that one that's
how we booked Clinton yeah
oh badass that's a bodega cat photo oh
yeah well I'm banged up right there yeah
oh there's stuffy
I took a similar one yeah
it was hard to find a pig without stop
holding cake but uh yeah that's my
childhood friend that's why it was fun I
was talking to him for a minute he's a
good good egg I like them all right is
this bad pod hey Doug key it's this is
visual stuff all right we're sorry guys
we've been drinking subscribe to the
YouTube channel youtube.com we might be
drunk all right
it's what we might be drunk pod was we
might be drunk taken
yeah my dad had it
I love you Dad well you're the one
that's so quiet well there was one
moment where I do declare Tom and I were
doing that the whole weekend but I do
declare just taking taking dollar bills
I do the class so you have insulted me
if any woman would like to suck our
Pekka we uh strap full of cash I
guarantee I will come quickly uh my dad
he was talking to me at one point and uh
you know I'm talking to him back he
won't respond you were there I think you
had checked out and list is across from
me and list is like getting all
uncomfortable and my dad walks away and
list goes I've never felt closer to you
and I was like what do you mean he's
like your dad is more Awkward than my
dad and I was like all right I'm glad
you got to see it so that was a nice
moment
couldn't get a word at him then he
roasted the [ __ ] out of me on the speech
yeah he got you good oh yeah oh [ __ ]
bedwetter over here
hey Mark remember when you pissed your
[ __ ] bed for years yeah pretty much
that was a speech that was about it well
good luck getting married now I know
he's like I've been sitting on all this
[ __ ] for being too old to do it I'm
hearing that I'm like I guess the
clock's ticking for me too then I'm
nowhere close so funny he was like you
know he's third what how old are you 39.
he's like he's 39 I'm like that's not
old in my world I don't know who you're
talking to both of you live damn it live
I'm living through you this is Billy
Madison Square grab your cheeks yes yes
stay here as long as you can yeah dude
every time I go to the beach with my
high school friends we go to Dewey Beach
all the time like you're gonna [ __ ] this
weekend I'm like no I'm hanging out with
you guys yeah we should [ __ ] some [ __ ]
like guys calm down uh you do you bring
your lady to Guatemala or you just go
guys go I just hang up you don't bring
your lady bring out by myself wow I
didn't see the world you don't want to
bring your lady that's the point of
being in a relationship Mexico City no
this is exploration I love you respond
to that
I don't know I turn my phone on silent
she knows what she signed up for she
knows what she signed up for and the
words of Bert R is good for small doses
I'm sitting on that for about a week
Mark thanks for pulling us out of a
10-minute lull the shop is literally
we're literally commenting photos for 10
minutes much like I got one locked and
loaded it's called Joe Sully that joke
just knocked out the shamish I don't
know what that is is that shamish the
middle candle yeah oh that Drew flow
flew higher than Kobe I'll tell you that
much
I'm just trying to I don't know what we
have here folks run some kobe beef all
right all right mamba
ah the Black Mamba yeah
um you could have gone after his kids
you didn't that was nice all right let's
not um
[ __ ] idiot come on I'm not saying the
kids I'm just saying he could have
what's that all right let's not get
carried away here either Alex is
bringing dates up I guess we're getting
clapped off here oh no we lost a tip we
lost a tip no ghost tits are [ __ ]
important we need the tits come on the
tits matter come on yeah Tit for Tat
yeah all right plug some dates coming up
the Bob Nelson gig right here
um Pittsburgh in January Salt Lake in
January Tampa February Denver I'm doing
a greatest hit show I've never done this
before what does that mean my best hits
from over the years that's fun wow I
don't remember mine yeah I gotta look
him up I gotta really yeah you listen to
albums Vancouver and then February show
just added San Jose I got Seattle which
is uh went on sale and uh The Beacon
Theater in New York City the biggest
show I've ever done whoa March 24th get
tickets at retrofair.com that's big baby
it's gonna be [ __ ] I'm gonna compete
with Seinfeld is he there is back at the
Beacon I don't think my audiences we got
uh we got Spokane OKC and then all
theaters from here on out building up so
New Orleans Austin Tulsa Dallas St Louis
Vegas uh Vancouver added a show they're
saying uh Vogue
so you're not you're doing it a month
before me oh you're not doing the uh
sold out nice bro we'll keep going
to [ __ ] uh Salt Lake City hopefully I
get into that NBA All-Star weekend we'll
see what happens uh AC Royal Oak
Michigan Minneapolis we're adding there
I think we did already I don't know
Madison [ __ ] what do you mean New
Haven Connecticut New Haven I don't know
look March 9th Boston we got a couple
there we're gonna add another in a
second so [ __ ] finish that one off uh
Miami Orlando we're almost done here you
got this Atlanta Charleston [ __ ]
Durham oh Charlottesville that's going
slow you're big you're not Norfolk big
no I'm not I'm [ __ ] not bro Norfolk
DC uh and Wilkes-Barre PA as well along
with Port Chester See on the road
samrel.com shows let's go hell yeah
you're doing like the country run damn
yeah and North Carolina
we're doing the [ __ ] bus bro
James Webber directed my special and
[ __ ] we got a tour manager Brian so
hell yeah James Webb doing videographing
or opening
great good video on that bus you and
Peter playing video games who gets the
big room I think I'm just gonna do two
lounges and bunks yeah we'll do a quiet
we'll do a quiet uh we'll do a quiet
Lounge in the back and a loud Lounge in
the front of people wanted just some
space I like it because I think I don't
need that I don't think he's sleeping
that bed for real I don't think I'm
gonna actually sleep nah no I think I
think everyone's overnight though I
didn't let everyone sleep in the same
situation I think we sleep in the bunks
I think we kind of adult bunks are
probably better anyway is it quiet
though oh yeah the bunks is quiet bunks
is quiet
but doesn't that open into the main room
no no no no no we get that we get the
back Lounge where we can just kind of
chill and be I'm like that one will be
if you want to get away from the Hang
right and the front one will be if you
want videos we'll put on like you know a
good movie maybe a [ __ ] game or
something play some PS5 wait wait scroll
up oh [ __ ] you missed it back
uh but yeah we did the the like you see
that's the veter door down in the bottom
middle there
um the doggy door we had a doggy door
you can come and go you can't poop on
the bus but you can he has a little
litter box Peter does represent the
Lollipop Guild
Mark Where Are You Gonna Be man um yeah
Mark say about your taste my I have not
updated my website but I got it up here
when is Hanukkah again
December 25th start January 12th oh no
no no Hanukkah does not start in January
dude oh 17th 17th okay maybe this is
over Cubs might be over then I'm at
Zanies Comedy Club the Blue Note in
Hawaii it's on it it's great really yeah
hold on look now hold on how are you
going for how long you going for uh well
I was gonna go for four nights no I got
a place in Kauai you gotta stay Kawaii
yeah yeah hook you up later I was
waiting for that I was gonna jump on it
yeah to pay for it if you want but I
have a spot for you yeah let's go then
doing Miami Improv again and then I'm
doing a bunch good dude improv is great
Miami is great gross yeah I mean I was
just in Fort Wayne Indiana
Miami's a good hang we get some good
Cuban food oh yeah go to the beach I
don't hate Miami I hate Miami I'm going
there a day early for my tour because
the Knicks are playing the [ __ ] heat
in Miami the night before my tour starts
in Miami
and little Gary gonna be [ __ ] behind
the bench giving middle fingers to Jimmy
Butler yeah not really because
and I respect them too much but slightly
behind your own finger just like you
know what's back here
I'm friends with Duncan Robinson but I'm
scared to ask for tickets because I'm
gonna be rolling in a [ __ ] Knicks
jersey you can't do it I can't do it
when you ever get those like uh the
[ __ ] you know producers or whatever
like Asian tickets for the Knicks or the
Rangers they're like come you cannot
wear the opposing and I'm like well I'm
not a fan of the Rangers are the [ __ ]
Knicks what am I gonna do I am yeah you
are
go Pals the Knicks have been uh quite a
Pelicans yeah the Knicks have had quite
a roster of celebs at the front lines
you notice that Gaffigan came out I saw
that I mean front lines well no what do
you call them Courtside it's not a war
Mark it's a good thing
The Trenches of the garden last night
give me third row you can see the
Foxhole seats that's what I call the Box
by the way Bodega catwhiskey.com
in Austin gave me a [ __ ] bottle I met
him he's a great guy he handed me a
bottle for someone else we love him we
love Chris yeah I'd like to add [ __ ] him
there you go yeah you know what fought
that guy yeah you changed mine you come
to the wedding no I invited him the day
before last minute yeah I told him to
invite him the day before and Mark was
like I'm on it and I was like probably
it doesn't work the day before yeah but
it's still it was still like you
remember you're like oh [ __ ] yeah he's
close I better come yeah we tried all of
Mark's invites were [ __ ] evites
that's right he did it well I don't know
I didn't do any of it we love you guys
thanks for listening watch ours if
you're a special Jew on YouTube right
now he's a good friend and we're proud
of him we're happy he came in today uh
Salamanca akoi Peters beard you beard
you what do you got to promote here
Brothers
here in December I'd say less so you've
been drinking these bro
not at all what are you talking about I
have no idea
slurry drunk because you could tell like
I know what level you're at and then um
after that if anyone is in Malaysia
Indonesia
where are you going uh
Malaysia's got sassy on you yeah
and then uh a little bit of uh Vietnam
and then South Korea and Japan oh how
long are you going for uh I have a
one-way ticket to Kuala Lumpur and then
working there nice should this be a
gingerbread Temple
oh it's yeah
well this has been a great episode we
love when Ari comes by classic as always
uh subscribe to we might be drunk and
thanks for listening guys get a glass
and free Palestine free Palestine day
three is about to go out
they threes out
together
[Music]
thank you
Bobby burned alive cause every Hanukkah
forgotten them in the frying Manish here
while we were having fun playing dreidel
smoker lines are wailing everywhere
firemen were breaking all the windows
Sadie closed his eyes began to pray no
luck our mouthpie down the stuck but
Bobby made us eat them anyway
I remember long ago when our family got
together little
Arkansas
[Music]
and that was Uncle Jaime's big mistake
my parents stood their beaming as they
called us and handed us the presents one
by one
is coming over
[Music]
[Music]
together
[Music]
magical I remember long ago when our
family got together
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
now he's always
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]